and
oh my gosh oh my gosh I'm so excited wait wait yeah look I got the humid
plus colors I'm starting a bit early I'm starting a bit early call hi y'all
I'm so excited I'm just like I'm gonna be mad annoying so YMF plus has asked me
to not share their audio so senpai you're gonna have to just watch with me
you're gonna have to watch in another window I'm gonna be so mad annoying you're
gonna be like shut up I want to hear the concert me I think the girls are doing
it call but I was just like oh no hundred percent though three three
I know you
because your dreams are coming true
I don't know what songs they're going to sing.
Okay.
Ha ha ha ha!
No way! This is her voice! It's so beautiful!
Ahhhh!
God, she did it!
Beautiful!
Oh my god! Ahhhh!
Ni-myo!
Oh my god!
Ni-myo! I love you!
Ni-myo!
Ahhhh! A great voice!
Everything will be okay!
On the way!
Ehhh!
Ahhhh!
Ni-myo!
I did it! I did it!
I love you!
Oh yeah! Oh yeah! Wow!
Wow! Fantastic!
Ahhhh!
Ohhhh!
I did it already!
I love you!
Ahhhh!
What the hell! They all sound fantastic!
What the?
Ahhhh!
It's so fantastic!
Ehhh!
What for?
Ahhhh!
Oh my gosh!
Mel and like Mimosa's voice are perfect!
They like suit each other so well!
Wow!
Ahhhh!
You are watching right?
I did it!
Punchy punchy!
Middle!
Ahhhh! There's all the Oslo!
We're never clicking away!
Ahhhh!
I did it!
What kind of voice?
No! They're beautiful!
Oh no! They're beautiful!
Middle! I didn't know you had such a voice on you!
Ahhhh!
Let's go!
Middle!
Middle! Middle! Middle!
Yay!
Middle!
Your voice range!
Ahhhh!
I love you, Metal!
You're so cute!
Ahhhh!
She's hitting the notes!
Yes!
We've all died in God of Heaven!
Go leave me!
Wow!
What a beautiful voice!
Ahhhh!
Yes! Yes! Yes!
Yes! Yes!
Yes!
Wow!
I'm me!
Yes!
Oh no!
What?
Wait, what did she say?
I'm pretty sure this is what it's called.
By that one group.
Ah, Millie!
You and me are in another edition.
This suits her so well!
Like her lore!
She's like a virtual playing doctor!
This is fantastic!
She's like an anti-virus and everything.
Action!
I am the train of the nation!
I am all of them!
You can be all of that to me!
I love you!
And I am finally reaching!
Lefty, I lefty, I left!
You have left, you have left!
This is fantastic!
Ah, the effect was so cool!
I love you!
I didn't even know she could turn into Shadow the Hedgehog!
Execution, execution, execution, execution, execution!
Ah, execute me!
You've already did it!
I did it!
Ah!
I love you!
Ah, you did great!
It suits her so well!
It suits her lore so well!
It's so good!
We said at the same time!
What song is it?
Da-dee-dee-dee!
Let's go!
Fuck! We lost his voice!
I mean his voice! Mano's voice!
They're all so good!
I love you!
Yay!
Oh, this is a hard song! They are doing it so well!
Why are they so good?
I'm so lucky to be able to do a watch log of this!
They're doing so good!
Ah!
Mano's so short too!
They have fantastic mics!
Ah!
I'm so excited!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh!
Her voice is so good!
I haven't heard her sing yet!
You man! You man unity! You man plus for life!
I hope you reach your you man!
I know this song!
Oh!
English version! I was like, I don't know what cover she's doing right now!
Oh, what the heck! Her voice is so cute!
Oh!
Why are they all so beautiful?
Her voice is so beautiful!
Yes!
She's so good! Her voice is so good!
Why are they all so beautiful?
The same!
People enjoy their dreams!
No!
Bear hate me girl!
Was this the Narissa version? No, it's not the Narissa version!
I know the Narissa version by heart!
The Narissa version goes...
Give me your love, all of your love!
This one is not doing that.
I love you! I love you! I love you!
Spain!
No! I'm always painting in love with you!
She's a weeb!
She's such a weeb! I love her!
I am unfortunately the weirdo who doesn't listen to music!
What song?
What song? What song? What song? What song? Tell me! Tell me! Tell me!
Is it magnet? Is it magnet? What song is it? Is it magnet?
What is it? What is it?
What is it with it?
They're bonding!
I know it! I know it! I know it! I know it's magnet!
I know it! I am such a psychic!
I am so... I'm a god!
When I rich version they're gonna do, I wonder if they're gonna do the English version or the JP version.
I have a song!
Oh my gosh! It's a mix!
It's a mix of English and JP!
What the heck!
It's forbidden love!
Oh my gosh, new metal!
I love this song! I remember when like every single person sung it and I love the twist that they always did.
I'm so mad annoying!
This is why I didn't want to go on a call with the other girls because I am...
All right! I'm singing the English version now!
Oh her voice is so soft! They're both singing beautifully!
Never mind!
Never take me to a concert! I'll be embarrassing!
I did it!
She's so psychic!
Oh, one day I'll stand on you!
I'll stand on the stage with you, Rain!
Serenity, you and me next for Magnet!
I love Magnet!
Okay, what's their duet song for this one?
Oh, it's a D- Ah, it's Dian Angel!
I haven't heard Dian Angel for so long!
Ah, Fujoshi!
Let's go! I did it!
I don't remember the song so I'm just gonna hum with them and not be annoying as annoying.
Oh my gosh, Fujoshi brain going brrrrrrrr.
Do you like the concert so far? It's amazing!
I'm so excited. I'm slapping my pencils together because I don't actually have bad lines.
Okay. Oh, oh, oh, oh, what a buildup.
Oh
You feel that that's straight to the heart
Oh my gosh, what a flashback
Oh
It's like I'm getting memory floods
Ow
I feel
Don't worry, I just hit the pen on my face
Oh
I got too excited, okay
Oh this guitar solo
You can tell this is like an anime they both really like
Oh
They love it they love the song
There in places are all too good
What are they gonna sing next
No, yes, this is the song
Oh
caramel
This is a hard song, okay? I even have trouble with the song, too.
I'm singing in all Japanese! Good!
I'm so excited!
This is such a nice song.
Oh my god! I'll never betray you!
Let's go! Let's go! Let's go! Let's go! Let's go!
Wait, that was too early.
I feel so bad that there's no 3D because you would not see my light dance right now using a pencil and a paintbrush.
It's so beautiful!
Oh, they're singing songs I like, too!
Idol?
Let's go!
Idol!
Mimosa!
Amy!
Oh, there are idols!
They're sparkling!
Shining!
Hi!
Spin!
You know?
Mimosa!
Amy!
Blah!
Angel!
Mimosa!
Hi!
I mean I mean me most of me most of I mean me most of
Joe
You
I
Was so enchanted
Fantastic
Yes, they are
They all did
You dreams I believe them
My dream is to be with you
Of course you shadow the hedgehog lover
Oh
My gosh, they are a k-pop group
You
Don't forget to leave a comment on
Their video
Oh
I'm sorry, I think it's so funny that they are like sorted out by height the tallest at the end
Are you all you may plus fans now I always was but you are now, right?
No
I'll rate into their too
It's over
That was so good
That was so fucking good
Thank you everyone for joining me on this wonderful watch along that has been sponsored by you met plus
Honestly, I would have watched it anyways because
You met plus I love the you met plus girls. They are very kind and good talented girls
And I think they need more eyes on them, okay?
well, I'll send you over to
Reyes, Reyes channel so you can all participate
And the after-party I will be in and out of there probably because I
Just have some things I made a lot of time to watch their concerts, but hopefully I'll see you there
Yeah, thank you so much, and thank you so much to
You met plus for
sponsoring this
Watch along please subscribe to area
rain
I'm me mimosa and metal
Their links will be in the description
I'm so glad everyone has joined me and
I'll see you again
next time
Scream for mercy and say hi to the girls cheer them on okay tell them how well they did
You